atlantic city c'est une station
balnéaire des états unis dans le new
jersey le metteur en scène louis malle
lit a situé son dernier film qui porte
d'ailleurs le nom de cette ville
atlantic city ce film est sorti hier
mercredi sur les écrans parisiens avec à
la fiche de lancaster susan sarandon et
michel piccoli alors un cadre et des
interprètes américain budget canadien
metteur en scène français on ne sait
plus très bien quelle étiquette mettre
sur votre film louis malle sais je vous
dirai d'abord que l'argent dans un film
c'est ce qu'a moins important c'est ce
qui est le plus important parce que on
ne le fait pas sans argent et c'est pas
ça qui donne la nationalité aux films
sinon ce serait très grave
c'est un film américain parce que le
sujet est américain et j'habite
actuellement aux etats unis je
travaillais aux états unis mais je crois
que enfin en tout cas beaucoup
d'américains m'ont dit que c'était quand
même un regard un peu d'étrangers sur
cette ville bizarre et assez fascinante
qui est un petit peu à l'image de
l'amérique d'aujourd'hui vous avez fait
deux films aux états unis plus un court
métrage
alors comment ressentez-vous l'affluence
de l'amérique à travers vos fils écoutez
ça c'est pas très facile pour moi de
répondre je crois que ça se traduit par
si vous voulez je crois quoi là quand on
travaille en est mais quand on est
obligés d'ajuster un petit peu disons
son écriture à ce qu'on filme c'est à
dire que la vie est beaucoup plus agitée
surtout atlantic city qu'ils à londres à
très très chaotique et je crois que par
exemple ce film là le rythme est
beaucoup plus vif que celui de certains
de mes films précédents
et puis j'ai voulu faire un film qui
soit sur un sujet un peu un peu macabre
comme ça un peu angoissant d'essayer de
faire un film qui soit un film drôle et
un film ironique pas méchant mais un peu
agressif et et surtout avec des
personnages qui existent et qu'ils
soient les personnages humains et qu'ils
soient touchant et c'est donc une
histoire de personnes si vous voulez
avec la ville qui est là derrière très
présent et mais pour vous justement ce
sont les personnages jouent c'est la
ville parce que la ville a une grosse
importance on peut croire c'est une
ville chimérique curieux vers soi
qu'elle existe mais on se demande si
elle meurt aussi elle n'a eu finalement
c'est à dire que c'est aussi une chose
qui est étonnant par l'amérique sait que
la frise une grande nostalgie du passé
mais en même temps ils détruisent leur
passé sans arrêt pour reconstruire
alors là cette ville a eu plusieurs
existences déjà et maintenant ils ont
légalisé le jeu c'est le boom des
casinos c'est la ruée vers l'or il
s'entraîne tout casser pour construire
22 casino alors évidemment la ville et
comme traumatisée
il ya un afflux de nouveaux arrivants
donc il y à cette espèce d'énergie
fantastique
moi quand j'étais athlète excité j'ai
été tellement impressionnée par la ville
que de toute évidence le scénario est
née de la ville et je pourrais dire
aussi que les personnages sont nées de
la ville le personnage que joue gros
lancaster on la rencontrait à partir de
là avec le scénariste du film john ware
on a on a essayé de de raconter une
histoire et on l'a on a construit notre
notre petit dentelle si vous voulez mais
en fait essentiellement c'est la ville
qui a inspiré le scénario et le film s'y
réfère constamment dans cette ville donc
deux points sont deux personnages
principaux on va les voir là justement
cours de dunes de leur rencontre un
repas dans un restaurant au casino le
casino roi du rebord girl au casino
mcdonald's les casinos pizza au casino
où je travaille il ratisse par jour un
million de dollars c'est vrai vous aimez
les casinos vous y allez souvent non non
je vais jamais c'est trop c'est trop
nickel pour moi c'est plein de bonnes
soeurs qui font la queue à l'entrée les
boy scouts même les pauvres mecs qui
viennent poser leurs allocations
familiales c'est devenu du jeu de gagne
petit avec tout le fric que vous
dépensez vous devez pas être un
gagne-petit dépenses et c'est bon pour
les mères est ce que véritablement
rencontre des personnages comme sa tante
etc
oui et non c'est à dire si vous voulez
le film est quand même voulu un peu
comme comme une fantaisie comme un
divertissement et mais je vais dire que
oui par exemple le personnage que je
suis un sound
elle elle vient à atlantic city pour
devenir croupier
alors il ya des milliers de jeunes gens
comme ça qui viennent ça peut la ruée
vers l'or parce qu'il ya tout ce travail
là et puis il ya aussi les j'ai voulu
opposer les anciens et les nouveaux le
personnage de lancaster qui est ce cette
espèce de de vieux gangster médiocre
était un garde du corps qui a vécu qui
est toujours vécue atlantic city et qui
tout d'un coup à la suite circonstances
du scénario se retrouve à la tête de
milliers de dollars et peut assouvir les
rêves toutes les chimères de toute sa
vie
c'est une histoire très très ironique
mais c'est essentiellement à une
histoire avec des personnages et
cétaphil dit c'est un film comique mais
ces cas ça donne quand même une
sensation d'apocalypse c'est ces gens
qui se défont complètement
ben oui mais je trouve que il vaut mieux
en rire parce que c'est je sais pas si
on va ré pu faire un film très
angoissant je crois que l' angoisse à
l'est derrière c'est un film en fait qui
appartient à plusieurs gens et à les
moments touchants il ya des moments bien
peu de tout mais essentiellement on n'a
pas voulu faire un film trop noir ou
trop pessimiste et on a essayé de faire
que que le spectateur puisse aimer les
personnages et et que les personnages
finalement mal gré alors que leurs
bizarreries et laure leur côté un peu
douteuses si vous voulez moralement en
tout cas soit les perçages sympathie
vous retournerez enfance l'human on veut
volontiers oui j'attends
merci